la siguiente tabla muestra los valores
de las funciones f y h y sus derivadas f
prima y h prima para x 3 lo que nos dice
es que para x igual a 3 el valor de f 6
es decir f de 3 es igual a 6 el valor de
h cero es decir hd 3 es igual a 0
la primera derivada de f evaluada en 36
y la primera derivada de h evaluada en 3
es 4 y se nos pide que evaluemos la
derivada con respecto a x del producto
de fx y hdx en x igual a 3 entonces
supongamos tener una función de x que
sea igual al producto de fx y hdx y como
puedes ver esta expresión es la derivada
de gmx entonces g prima de x es igual a
la derivada con respecto a x pf x
por hdx ahora observa es exactamente lo
mismo que tenemos aquí y queremos
evaluarlo en x igual a 3 es decir
queremos evaluar a g prima en 3g prima
de 3 esto es lo que se nos pide
encontrar entonces para hacer eso veamos
primero esto se nos pide que tomemos la
derivada con respecto a x del producto
de dos funciones de las cuales ya
tenemos información tomamos la derivada
del producto de las dos funciones
entonces bueno aquí lo que nos sirve es
la regla del producto con la regla del
producto esto será igual a la derivada
de la primera función f prima de x
multiplicada por la segunda función hdx
así sin tomar la derivada más la primera
función f x sin tomar su derivada
multiplicada por la derivada de la
segunda función h prima de x ahora
queremos evaluar a g prima en 3 queremos
la derivada de g evaluada en 3
entonces g prima de 3 es igual a efe
prima de 3
multiplicada por h de tres más
efe de 3 x h prima de 3 y bueno vaya
suerte porque observa que usando esta
tabla podemos resolver esto
efe prima de 3 a que es igual veamos en
la tabla cuando x es igual a 3
efe prima de x es igual a 6 así que esto
es 6 ahora
ht 3 cuando x es igual a 3 ht x es igual
a 0 así que esto es 0
efe de tres cuando x es igual a tres f x
es igual a 6 así que esto es 6 y
finalmente h prima de tres cuando x es
igual a 3 h prima de x es igual a 4 así
que h prima de 3 es igual a 4 esto es 4
y bueno ahí lo tienes entonces g prima
de 3 es igual a 6 x 0 eso es 0 + 6 por 4
eso es igual a 24 por lo tanto la
derivada de g evaluada en 3 es igual a